day and night workers flow quietly in
and out of this giant Warehouse in the
Midlands
but for several months now a Revolt has
been brewing here at Amazon sorting
Center in Coventry
Darren Westward one of the company's
workers has been instrumental in
drumming up support for a strike
the company's first ever in the UK I'm
working for one of the richest companies
in the world in one of the richest
countries and all I'm asking for isn't
money enough to live I don't think
that's too much
a cost of living crisis has forced the
largely ununionized Workforce to
organize and demand more pay from the
online Giant
they walked out at midnight filing past
their managers and colleagues
hopefully we get more pay and
we'd have to over to the overtime to
survive what pay rise we've got
unfortunately it's not enough if this
doesn't send a message to the people
above I don't know what else can
workers and additional 50p taking their
hourly wage to 10 pounds 50 an hour it
amounts to a five percent pay rise but
of course it's no pay rise at all when
you consider the fact that inflation has
been running at close to 11 percent
starting salaries at Amazon are still
higher than the national minimum wage
the company said we appreciate the great
work our teams do throughout the year
and we're proud to offer competitive pay
which starts at a minimum of between 10
pounds 50 and 11 pounds 45 per hour
depending on location
their wages may have risen but inflation
is hurting these workers those on the
lowest incomes at the most
and they're letting it be known girl on
Sky News in Coventry